you know what i did yesterday for the
first time held a baby never held a baby
before it's freaky isn't it yeah yeah
who let you hold that kelsey's friend
came over she has a six month
child her and her husband came over and
uh they're like you want to hold the
baby and i was like i don't uh i don't
yep you know i thought it would be like
real slippery it was a good experience
you know
they're soft
yeah they are really soft nah i'm always
worried like any time i've held a baby i
always throw it back
because i know their heads are soft
boiled i'm always like yo get this [ __ ]
away from me i feel like if i sneeze too
hard like his face is like the back of
his head he's just gonna deflate get it
away i don't i don't want this
responsibility i know i was really
nervous so i did it sitting first
because that's like the step towards
standing i didn't hate how encouraging
they are like no stand up do a spin yeah
yeah toss him in the air yeah he loves
it it's fine no i did it standing and
the mom comes out of the bathroom and
because he's like he did a standing hold
and she was like what do you mean is
that a trick or what do you mean
standing hold is he on a skateboard tony
hawk's pro fatherhood yes
exactly that's [ __ ]
hold 500 points kick flip
is that baby in the little
did you get baby fever yeah i mean i've
i've had it for a bit really yeah you
want a child probably 70 percent of the
time i really like i really want one and
then we go traveling somewhere or
something even yesterday like hanging
out with them it was great but they were
like just everything is the baby one of
them was always carrying it walking it
and they're like oh it's just it's [ __ ]
sleeping
which i'm like ready for but still it's
gonna be a shock this is every
conversation with people with a newborn
uh-huh
yeah yeah yeah yeah sorry yeah yeah can
you up on me again
sorry my [ __ ] tits hurt yeah go ahead
i will say though the amount of time
they hung out with us for was perfect
because of the baby
no no i don't mean that in a mean way at
all i don't mean no no no i'm black at
all you are not gonna have a baby just
so you could be an introvert
you [ __ ] i'm saying it's good
for an introvert
[ __ ] it's good for an introvert
babe i just thought of the best way to
get out of every social interaction no
but you know you've probably used the
excuse before i gotta go feed the dog
yeah i've used that but i try to mean it
yeah i mean the dog has to eat
eventually
you know
it was great i really loved hanging out
with them but they came over and we set
up all the [ __ ] and we had a great
conversation and then they were like
okay we got to go his nap is thing you
know whatever the [ __ ] and i was like
great yeah okay hour and a half in and
out i can't wait to do that yeah we'll
come by but i don't think we can stay
for that long because of his he's gotta
we got to make sure he's the veteran
you know i can't wait for that so we
have we'll stop by for sure pop in hi
how's it going good how are you how's
wife how's work cool we gotta go
you know then you still show face but no
one's like oh they left early because
they're you know flakes or whatever
sorry i was just really taken aback by
that evangelical speaking in tongues
i thought that was a message from god
right there
that's interesting i didn't realize you
had high baby fever yeah i really i'm
looking forward to it interesting i'm on
the fence the baby fence
yeah sometimes like the idea of adopting
i'm intrigued by the idea of drafting a
free agent a free agent no contract i'm
not gay man they didn't believe in you
but i see talent yeah i see the way you
color in those lines you know you get on
that leap frog and you get into that
racing game
i see your time
i'll see you shad around okay yeah so
you're just gonna pick the kid that's
gonna become a good racer could be a lot
he could be good anything but you know
to all my orphans out there race car
driving experience we look for that here
at the miller household we recruit all
kinds of talent but if you're fast on
track best believe is there like an
email or something they can reach out to
yeah just hit me up man me and lina one
of our friends had a really interesting
argument for adoption she said she likes
the idea of adoption and her words were
i don't know it's a kid isn't it if you
want the experience of raising a child
that is a child it's kind of
narcissistic just to go through with one
because you want it to look like you
yeah i was like damn you calling me a
narcissist yes for wanting to happen no
the one that one that looks like you
right i don't really care if it looks
like me
what just some cucks on reddit being
like oh that can be a ring
cody you bring up an interesting point i
agree there is something very exciting
about it
being someone other than yourself
i tried to convince her she's like no it
should be between us i say
i really hope it looks like my wife's
boyfriend because he's hot that guy is
cool man that cool as hell that guy
rules bro he's so tall nah inverse he's
a cool little guy yeah you only bought
five four but you know [ __ ] hung like
a truck
good guy guy's got a [ __ ] freight
engine on him that boy's got a schmeeter
yeah i wonder if that's a kink cucking
yourself with someone who's not more
alpha than you yeah to piss you off okay
that that's gonna be the turn of the
century yeah big dick guys get their
shine for years and years and then it's
like you know what let's mix it up
seeking one beta bowl must be smaller
than four inches big dick guys are out
of work so then the husband gets pissed
that she's cheating on him with a guy
with a small dick small dick and like
unassuming stature right how could you
[ __ ] cheat on me with that little
runt so so hot
god that is sexy